seize morts ces dernières 24 heures les
émeutes et les pillages continuent en
argentine malgré l'état de siège
il y à une heure les syndicats ont
appelé à la grève générale la démission
du ministre de l'économie a été acceptée
la mort d'une grande figure de l'afrique
léopold sédar senghor est décédé
aujourd'hui à 95 ans ministre du général
de gaulle puis président du sénégal
pendant vingt ans il était aussi le
poète de la négritude encore un incendie
criminel au havre cette fois c'est un
collège qui a été partiellement détruit
le jour même où les enseignants étaient
en grève contre la violence que faire
contre la délinquance des mineurs
l'enquète de cette émission dans ce
qu'on appelait autrefois une maison
correction jack lang relance le dossier
du calendrier scolaire cette fois c'est
sûr les vacances de la toussaint
passeront de sept à 10 jours pour tout
le monde
à paris le recteur propose la semaine de
cinq jours après ce journal questions
ouvertes la crise argentine peut-elle
faire boule de neige l'euro est il déjà
adopté invité laurent fabius le ministre
de l'économie
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
l'état de siège a donc était décrété la
nuit dernière en argentine pour une
durée de 30 jours
mais cela ne suffit pas visiblement pour
endiguer les manifestations
manifestations de la fin au départ avec
de nombreux pillages et des commerçants
qui n'ont pas hésité à tirer il y à 16
morts à l'heure qu'il est et puis les
rassemblements ont pris un tour quasi
insurrectionnelle
c'est le pouvoir et sa politique
d'austérité qui est maintenant viser à
nha trang jeu nous ou vieux hommes ou
femmes
la police montée argentine ne fait pas
dans le détail la charge et violent même
pour les chevaux mais peu efficace pas
plus que les tirs de balles en
caoutchouc ou les arrestations musclées
rien n'y fait même les seize morts des
dernières 24 heures à peine disperser la
foule se regroupent
toujours dans les environs de la place
de mai le coeur du pouvoir à buenos
aires la foule décidé semble-t-il en
finir avec le gouvernement et sa
politique qui a mené le pays au bord de
la faillite
nous devons nous battre jusqu'au bout
hurle ce monsieur en cravate nous
n'avons aucune autre solution ajoute
cette femme
nous n'avons pas d'issue nous sommes
désespérés à siéger en quelque sorte
dans le palais présidentiel fernando de
la rúa a refusé la démission de son
gouvernement
exception faite du ministre de
l'économie hier soir il a décrété l'état
de siège en appelant la population au
calme
il n'a fait que relancer les violences
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin le centre de
buenos aires a été livrée aux émeutiers
cible privilégiée le ministère de
l'économie ou encore ici le parlement
les violences ont changé de nature on
s'en prend moins aux commerçants commis
hier en ligne de mire désormais la tête
de l'état alors comment expliquer cette
crise économique bien spécifique à
l'argentine à quelques points de repères
l'argentine est un pays grand comme cinq
fois la france peuplé de 36 millions
d'habitants et qui a toujours été une
nation relativement riches plus riches
que la france même après la guerre et
qui compte par exemple à son actif trois
prix nobel de sciences ce n'est donc pas
un problème de développement mais un
problème financier
en cause notamment la parité entre le
peso argentin et le dollar emilie lens
on y lit à 60 ans l'argentine était l'un
des dix pays les plus riches du monde
une sorte de suisse de l'amérique du sud
en 91 pour faire face à une
hyperinflation elle décide d'aligner sa
monnaie sur le dollar
un peso égale désormais un dollar dans
un premier temps ça marche
les investisseurs retrouvent confiance
mais l'argentine vit au dessus de ses
moyens et le climat international ne lui
est pas favorable
les concurrents de l'argentine dans la
région comme le brésil ont dévalué
fortement donc les produits argentins
sont devenus moins compétitifs et en
même temps le dollar s'est réévalué donc
l'argentine a été prise à la gorge
donc la solution à ce moment là aurait
été de revenir sur ce système qui ne
marchait plus on l'a maintenu et comme
on l'a maintenu et bien pour faire les
fins de mois
on sait de plus en plus endettés et
aujourd'hui ils font payer la note
dans certaines régions on compte 40 % de
chômeurs chaque jour 2000 personnes
tombent sous le seuil de pauvreté
l'argentine fait tout son possible pour
ne pas dévaluer le personne voudrait
alors plus rien seul une aide
internationale massive devrait permettre
à l'argentine ne surmonter la crise un
mot de la colombie voisine nous vous
parlions hier de cet enfant de 12 ans
mort d'un cancer son père retenu en
otage par la guérilla n'avait pu le
revoir malgré les appels du pays tout
entier et bien les obsèques de l'enfant
était célébrée aujourd'hui elles ont
réuni des milliers de personnes qui ont
lancé à cette occasion des appels à la
paix civile à new york c'est difficile à
croire mais c'est la vérité ça n'est que
cette semaine depuis hier ou avant-hier
que l' incendie du world trade center a
été complètement éteint le feu couvait
dans les ruines depuis trois mois et dix
jours donc c'est évidemment l'incendue
le plus importante les états unis aient
jamais connues la police a rendu
publique une vidéo prises d'hélicoptère
le 11 septembre juste après le double
impact images très impressionnantes vous
allez voir que l'appareil tente sans
succès de se poser au sommet de l'une
des tours pour sauver des vies
commentaires olivier caroff l'enfer et
droit devant eux
à bord de cet hélicoptère de la police
de new york un secouriste filme au plus
près juste sous l'appareil
les étages supérieurs des tours jumelles
déjà dévoré par l' incendie
l'équipage décide de se poser à
proximité dans un parc
les hommes à bord n'ont pas encore
conscience mais leur vie sont en train
de se jouer à cet instant précis
lorsque la première course et fondre ils
viennent à peine de redécollé à une ou
deux minutes fret le linceul de fumée
qui envahit manhattan les aurait
enseveli
nous aussi témoins impuissants ils vont
s'abriter de l'autre côté de la baie
lorsque la seconde tour s'écroule
aucun des policiers n'a le coeur de
regarder diffusé la nuit dernière alors
même sous les décombres du world trade
center cesser enfin de brûler cette
vidéo vient dire aux new yorkais qui si
la journée du 11 septembre ne s'est
jamais vraiment terminé dernier bilan
communiqué aujourd'hui revu à la baisse
de 1992 mort à new york à symbole
important aujourd'hui le trafic avec
liberty island l'île où se trouve la
statue de la liberté a repris la statue
elle reste fermée au public en
afghanistan d'abord cette image du
retour à la normale celle d'une jolie
mariée tout sourire et tout en blanc il
y avait aussi du tulle ou la dentelle
sur la voiture pas d'angélisme pour
autant la charia la loi islamique par
exemple était en vigueur avant les
talibans elles le restent après les
talibans mais en version plus clémentes
écoutez bien c'est très sérieux
un juge interrogé par la sp a ainsi
indiqué que les lapidations
continueraient mais avec des pierres
plus petit qu'avant sur place à kaboul
eric monier bruno girodon cinq années de
régime taliban ont laissé aux vieux
jalil un souvenir indélébile un affreux
souvent accusée de vol il a subi toute
la rigueur de la charia la loi islamique
un matin dans le stade national
archicomble les étudiants en religion
lui ont tranché la main un châtiment
pour servir de leçon aujourd'hui le
vieil homme voue une haine aux talibans
parce qu'il était innocent plaide-t-il
sans remettre en cause pour autant le
principe de ce type de sentence
la charia doit rester la règle dans la
loi afghane
depuis la fuite des talibans il ya un
peu plus d'un mois le stade a été rendu
à sa vocation le football ici on
amputait les voleurs on exécutait les
assassins où les femmes coupables
d'adultère
pour l'heure personne ne sait si de tels
spectacles seront à nouveau organisé en
afghanistan au tribunal de kaboul ni
audience ni procès on attend les
directives du nouveau gouvernement d'en
savoir quelles lois appliquées et
certains comme le juge paola ou izia au
lac magistrats sous la monarchie comme
sous le règne des talibans plaide pour
le maintien d'une justice implacable où
la loi du coran c'est clair on coupe les
mains des voleurs la charia la loi
islamique existe ici je pense que ça
continuera
personne ne la remettra en cause les
tenants de la torture des amputations
des exécutions sommaires n'ont pas tous
disparu avec les talibans au sein même
de la coalition qui s'installera au
pouvoir samedi on compte des partisans
d'une justice impitoyable et qui
n'entendent pas remettre en cause tout
l'héritage talibans aussi cruelle soit
il en ce qui concerne la traque de ben
laden le ministre américain de la
défense donald rumsfeld indiqué que des
centaines de membres d'al qaïda étaient
détenus au pakistan
images ici de prisonnier sur la base
américaine de kandahar
les partisans les plus haut placés de
ben laden sont transférés sur un navire
américain qui croise en mer doman pour
interrogatoire ils sont actuellement au
nombre de 23 ans bref toujours à
l'étranger petits signes positifs au
proche orient les forces israéliennes se
sont partiellement retiré aujourd'hui de
deux villes de cisjordanie sous contrôle
palestinien
naplouse et ramallah des blindés sont
toutefois maintenus à 300 mètres des
bureaux de yasser arafat
en revanche le ramasse
un démenti avoir renoncé aux attentats
suicide comme nous vous l'annoncions
hier
l'afrique vient de perdre l'un de ses
plus grands dirigeants léopold sédar
senghor était le père du sénégal
indépendant c'est à lui que le pays doit
sa stabilité politique si rare en
afrique
senghor était aussi un grand poète
geneviève moll
c'était en 1984 léopold sédar senghor
était le premier africain entre l
académie française est un jeu halo sud
de dakar en 1906 ils étaient
minoritaires dans son pays sérère et
catholiques dans ce sénégal en majorité
wolof et musulmans condisciple de
georges pompidou et d'aimé césaire à
l'école normale supérieure il en sort
agrégé de grammaire qui considérait
comme d'armature nécessaire de la langue
française il est en plus l'apprentissage
la grammaire et de la grammaire à
l'ancienne c'est un apprentissage de la
vie en société parce que la vie en
société
elle est aussi absurde que la grammaire
ça apprend à à jouer avec des règles
absurdes enseignants avant la deuxième
guerre mondiale il était déjà le poète
de la négritude
il revendiquait sa spécificité de noir
sa culture de signes d'émotion de mx
mais il ne rejetait pas pour autant sa
culture occidentale socialisme ministre
du général de gaulle puis président du
sénégal durant 20 ans il a tenté avec
difficulté que sorties au pays du
sous-développement
toute ma vie j'ai essayé d'enseigner à
mon peuple le sens de la mesure
le sens de la complémentarité le sens du
métissage culturel le 31 mai 1981 il
n'était pas un son mandat de président
il se retirait en normandie
il remplaçait disait deal avec d'humour
et négritude par la normandie tude
l'afrique a perdu un visionnaire et la
france 1 à me senghor était un passeur
de culture dit jacques chirac ce soir
tristesse et révolte à la cité des
aubiers à bordeaux le corps d'enfant
retrouvé hier est bien celui du petit
larbi disparu depuis le 4 décembre
c'est sa famille qui l'a identifié les
enquêteurs restent perplexes
l'autopsié pratiquée ce matin n'a pas
permis de déterminer précisément les
causes de sa mort sur place eric terrain
bernard bonne arme il n'y a ce soir
qu'une seule certitude le corps retrouvé
hier près de cette peine est bien celui
de larbi faneuse 10 ans et demi malgré
les 50 enquêteurs du srpj mobiliser les
pôles minutieuse les investigations dans
les immeubles les questions sur la date
et les causes du décès restent sans
réponse le top 6 ne nous donne pas de
manière claire les causes de la mort
l'enfant ne porte pas de traces de
violences sexuelles je n'ai pas dit
qu'il n'a pas eu une relation sexuelle
ça c'est les analyses qui nous le diront
incompréhension tristesse aux aubiers
l'émotion est à la hauteur de la
solidarité de la dignité dont font
preuve depuis le début de la sphère les
habitants la cité à la gorge serrée
on nous avait dit quasi disparu j'étais
déjà j'avais déjà peur des esprits mal
et nous avons fait quoi c'est
consternant c'est très dur
bon c'est l'enfant qui est à l'école
avec larbi c'est vrai que c'est très dur
quoi c'est un petit peu notre enfant qui
parti comment encaisser un tel choc à
l'école ce matin l'équipe pédagogique
assisté d'une psychologue a réuni les
enfants premier temps d'hier avec certes
des mots choisis la vérité la mort d'un
camarade la recherche des coupables
deuxième temps favoriser l'expression
pour identifier ceux qui ont besoin d'un
soutien sont les enfants qui a découvert
le corps sans les enfants de la classe
mais le petit garçon était un petit
garçon très connu dans le quartier
et il ya sûrement d'autres d'autres amis
à lui qui sont si très traumatisée ce
soir tout le monde ici a une pensée pour
la famille samedi une marche silencieuse
est prévue la cité des aubiers est en
deuil les suites d'une affaire très
sensible en 97 un policier avait tué
abdelkader bouziane un adolescent qui
avait forcé un barrage
la chambre de l'instruction de la cour
d'appel d'orléans vient de prononcer un
non lieu
c'est donc finalement la thèse de la
légitime défense qui l'a emporté à
l'époque la sphère avait provoqué de
violents affrontements à dammarie les
lys
stéphane breitner depuis quatre ans la
cité de dammarie-les-lys attendait un
procès tous ici espérer que laurent le
chiffre un policier qui avait tué l'un
des leurs en 97 soit traduit devant une
cour d'assises mais cet après midi le
policier a bénéficié d'un non lieu
franchement se prend une balle dans la
nuque un non-lieu en a aucune arme nous
pour se battre contre ces gens là nous
on pense que la zone de non droit n'est
pas dans les quartiers dits sensibles
aller chez eux dans les palais de
justice
c'était dans la nuit du 17 décembre 97
abdelkader bouziane prise en chasse par
la brigade anticriminalité arrive à un
carrefour en face un barrage de police
il tente de le contourner
laurent le chiffre tir est une jeune
homme le policier invoque la légitime
défense pourtant la reconstitution fui
lé expertises balistiques viendront
contredire sa version
le lendemain soir des émeutes éclatent
dans la cité dammarie-les-lys tout le
monde affirme que le policier a
volontairement tué khadr
pour calmer ses accès de violence la
famille de la victime organisent une
marche silencieuse sans incident ce soir
un dispositif de veille composée de 120
policiers se tient prête à intervenir en
cas d'incidents à propos de police
réactions plutôt positives des syndicats
aux rapports de julien dray sur les
aménagements apportés à la loi sur la
présomption d'innocence on l'évoqué
tiers à l'action plus contrastées chez
les magistrats
la garde des sceaux marylise lebranchu
reste elle très prudente elle estime que
les pistes explorées sont intéressantes
mais que la loi n'est pas remise en
cause
chronique du vandalisme au havre nouvel
incendie la nuit dernière cette fois
c'est un collège qui était visé je vous
rappelle que deux gymnases de la ville
ont été détruits depuis la rentrée sur
place paul de genève gilles aymard les
collèges étaient pleins quand l'
incendie s'est déclaré à vite
le premier étage est envahie par la
fumée bleue quand les élèves dans leur
classe on appuie avec j'ai parlé par les
fenêtres les pompiers sans sans incident
majeur
quelques années certains des élèves sont
choqués comme un incendie est vite
maîtrisé les pompiers retrouvent un
bidon vide sur les lieux pour la police
l'auteur certains élèves de
l'établissement situé en plein coeur des
quartiers difficiles du havre le collège
jean moulin n'échappe à la montée de
l'insécurité
confronté à cette violence les
professeurs demandent des moyens on peut
lier donc ces événements peut-être au
fait que l'administration que les
pouvoirs délaisse
les justes les structures scolaires
délaissent les structures sociales dans
ce quartier du havre qui aurait quand
même bien besoin d'un soutien depuis le
mois de septembre un parking souterrain
deux gymnases et ce centre de loisirs
ont été incendiés au à deux de ces
affaires ont déjà été résolus pour la
police les coupables sont à chaque fois
différents
en revanche leur motivation semble
toujours les mêmes ce sont surtout des
bâtiments municipaux qui sont visés et
est-ce que c'est pas une manière de
lutter sur un territoire de conserver un
territoire c'est tout à fait possible
ces incendies à répétition serait un
défi lancé aux institutions mais aussi
l'expression d'un véritable malaise
question en tout cas que faire des
mineurs délinquants c'est que la prison
risque le plus souvent de les plonger
définitivement dans l'univers de la
délinquance pour beaucoup les centres
éducatifs renforcés sont souvent la
seule issue c'est ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les maisons de correction des
jeunes privés de tout repère apprennent
tout simplement la vie en société le
respect le travail les horaires celle en
quête de cette édition à la ménardière
dans le vercors six délinquants neuf
éducateurs enquête signée valérie
fournioux et philippe quéron réveil
tonique aller devant cette heure c'est
leur première règle à respecter pour les
six délinquants mineurs de la mine
arrière
la ponctualité car le chantier du jour
les attend
débroussaillage une façon comme une
autre de les fatiguer de les conduire
tous ont commis des vols certains avec
violence ils sont multirécidivistes tous
déscolarisés refusant l'autorité et part
ils nous voient comme des ennemis en
fait comme les agresseurs alors que bon
un petit à petit on va leur faire
comprendre qu'on est là pour les aider
pour les soutenir pour les années
évoluer seuls 6 cham est un petit
incendiaires de 14 ans dans son quartier
il brûle régulièrement des poubelles
sens fatigué comme ici les sens en
brique et le cadre aussi est différent
dans le vercors
ils sont ici loin de leurs repères
perdus dans la nature pas bien c'est dur
en quoi je parle pour le lait pour les
appareils que la ville
la boîte à leclerc carrefour tu as des
magasins tout près et s'il faut la
casque est le même pour acheter du pain
ou la rééducation passe aussi par
l'apprentissage de règles simples comme
mettre le couvert chez eux livrés à eux
mêmes ils mangent quand ils ont faim en
se servant dans le frigo
si toi tu la mettais l'atteindre c'est
toute une hygiène de vie à revoir les
angevins qui savait pas se doucher la
régularité dans son ensemble du corps
qui connaissait pas les répercussions
justement vraiment que d'hygiène savais
pas donc en fait on reprend tout ça avec
eux pour leur confort il n'avait pas le
choix c'était soit la ménardière soit la
prison mais ici les règles sont
difficiles à supporter pour eux pour sa
trahison des traitements qu'il est calme
pour pour pas craqué et toi oui j'ai un
traitement qui est qui et qui va me
calmer si tu craques passerait comment
je pense qu'il y aura déjà un conflit et
après on est une fille et je pense alors
moi j'hésite à dame par rapport aux
festivités
c'est investissent dans tout ce qui est
mis en place une armée en toi c'est dur
pour anthony 17 ans mais la prison il
connaît déjà il ne veut plus y retourner
diouf
présenté très inquiet ça m'apporte rien
après en prison c'est l'engrenage la
minaudière c'est une structure en fait
c'est comme une structure d'apprendre et
apprend des choses que ben t'as pas
réussi à prendre avant ils te mettent un
peu pourri tu apprennes à retourner dans
la société et sincère congrès au bout de
cinq mois d'enfermement ici seuls 20%
récidive voilà bien sûr ce genre
d'établissement coûte cher 2000 francs
par jour et par enfant mais cette à
peine plus que la prison leur nombre a
triplé même plus en trois ans mais il
reste faible 43 centres éducatifs
renforcés en france à l'heure qu'il est
à propos d'enfants la secte tabitha
places mises en cause le procureur de la
république de pau a mis en examen l'un
de ses membres six enfants qui devaient
être placés dans des foyers n'ont pas
été présentés agnès gardait jean-pierre
philo ses membres de la secte tabitha
space déféré au parquet de pau hier
après midi il a été placé sous contrôle
judiciaire
on lui reproche d'avoir soustrait ses
six enfants à la justice et organiser
leur fuite des enfants dont un juge
venait d'ordonner le placement en foyer
pour défaut de scolarisation les
contrôles avaient permis de constater
des carences très grave
en ce qui concerne l'enseignement qui
étaient dispensés à ses enfants
outre les problèmes médicaux que ses
enfants pouvaient rencontrer puisque le
suivi médical le set totalement à
désirer absence de soins médicaux refus
de vacciner les enfants pas d'école en
dehors de la secte
voilà en substance les principes qui
régissent la vie de cette communauté en
avril 97 un bébé de 19 mois avaient
trouvé la mort
atteint d'une malformation cardiaque ses
parents avaient refusé toute
intervention chirurgicale
condamné depuis à 12 ans de prison
justice et politique vers une série de
non lieu spectaculaire dans la sphère
des emplois fictifs de la mnef le
parquet de paris a requis en ce sens
dans 17 cas concernés notamment le
député ps jean-marie le guen l'ancien
numéro deux du parti jean-christophe
cambadélis ainsi que l'ancienne
conseillère de lionel jospin marie
france lavarini le parquet évoque
notamment la prescription c'est
maintenant au juge en charge du dossier
de décider josé bové condamné en appel à
six mois de prison ferme pour la
destruction de plants de riz
transgénique expérimentaux et l'ancien
porte-parole de la confédération
paysanne n'ira cependant pas en prison
en tout cas pas dans l'immédiat car elle
va se pourvoir en cassation jusque là il
n'avait été condamné qu'à des peines
avec sursis
le pc et les verts font part de leur
indignation après cette condamnation
nouvelle grève dans le secteur de la
santé cette fois celle des infirmiers
libéraux ils sont 47 mille en france et
réclame une revalorisation de leurs
tarifs pour la piqûre actuellement
facturé 17 francs 50 doit passer à 25
francs et l'indemnité forfaitaire de
déplacement facturé 9 francs à 12 francs
le quotidien de l'une de ses infirmières
à lyon reportage benoît gallerey le jour
est à peine levé et mireille gilet court
déjà c'est tout un trousseau de clés de
personnes qui vivent seules 20 patients
a visité en une seule matinée la plupart
des personnes âgées
et oui la vieille dame est diabétique
chaque matin les mêmes soins une
glycémie une piqûre d'insuline 15
minutes de soins payés 4 euros 26 francs
25 par la sécurité sociale ni crier au
même tarif
ça fait plus de 13 ans combien au même
tarif
avec le développement de
l'hospitalisation à domicile
ces prises en charge sont de plus en
plus nombreuses et pourtant mireille
refuse des malades
elle est soumise à des quotas imposés
par la sécurité sociale
on aimerait que les quotas soient
supprimées pour au moins qu'on puisse
travailler en toute sérénité et
permettre aussi aux infirmières plus
jeunes de s'installer
il faut une bonne condition physique
pour exercer le métier 10 heures de
travail par jour un week-end sur deux
est toujours un petit mot pour les
familles c'est si je n'avais pas je sais
je sais pas ce que je ferai honnêtement
je ne pourrais plus me raye espère comme
ses collègues obtenir du gouvernement la
retraite à 60 ans la relève est loin
d'être assurée les jeunes infirmières
hésitent à s'installer
et puis à noter c'est important que le
principal syndicat de médecins
généralistes appellent à la fermeture
des cabinets pendant la période des
fêtes et médecins qui demandent eux
aussi une revalorisation de leurs tarifs
à la hausse en tout cas les cigarettes
deux des principaux fabricants altadis
l'ex seita et british american tobacco
annonce une hausse moyenne des prix de
10 et de 7 7% il s'agit de compenser
l'alourdissement des prélèvements
fiscaux destinés notamment à financer
les 35 heures ce sera à partir du 1er
janvier
à propos des 35 heures est de la censure
du conseil constitutionnel lionel jospin
a estimé aujourd'hui que le financement
de la réforme n'était pas en cause il ne
s'agit que d'une pure annulation
comptable dit il le débat sur les
rythmes scolaires à paris le rectorat
propose donc le samedi libre remplacé
par l'école du mercredi
la consultation est en cours décisions
nationales en revanche annoncé par jack
lang ce matin sur notre antenne
les vacances de la toussaint vont bien
passé de sept à dix jours claude
polanski françois privat il déborde
encore d'énergie mais leurs ressources
ne sont pas inépuisables
en 2002 ils auront trois jours de
vacances en plus à la toussaint du
mercredi 23 octobre au lundi 4 novembre
c'est une très bonne chose les enfants
sont fatigués en trimestre le conte
trimestre dure quatre mois donc
automatiquement ils sont fatigués il ya
un mois de trop bon on peut pas sortir
donné un mois de vacances en plus mes
dix jours de vacances voire quinze jours
ce serait parfait agitation mon
attention symptômes très mystérieux et
oui
ou plutôt c'est gratuit après un premier
trimestre très lourd ces trois jours
supplémentaires font l'unanimité chez
les enfants je ne reposerait pluies et
puis je pourrais bien jouer avec mes
copines avec mes petits plats un mois ça
serait bien au départ être ce n'est pas
le même son de cloche enfin faire garder
les enfants un peu plus et c'est pas
forcément la bonne solution je trouve
qu'ils ont déjà pas mal de vacances
moi je vois pas l'intérêt de
l'allongement des vacances mais par
contre les rythmes de ce collège chocs
sont trop lourds la journée pour des
mois j'ai un enfant de 6 ans chantait
soyaux aujourd'hui en effet c'est
l'ensemble des rythmes scolaires qui
devraient être repensées et pour mettre
en route ce nouveau calendrier
peut-être faudra-t-il raccourcir les
grandes vacances puisqu'on évoque les
vacances si vous avez prévu de partir au
ski n'oubliez pas d'emmener de la
lecture beaucoup de stations sont en
manque de neige et tout ne dispose pas
de canon pour préparer les pistes
d'où l'idée de mettre en place un
système de mutuelles de compensation en
quelque sorte pour indemniser les
stations les plus malchanceuses
reportage à la clusaz vincent fourcade
thierry simonet niché à 2300 mètres
d'altitude
val thorens la plus haute station
d'europe n'a pourtant pas vu tomber le
moindre flocon de neige depuis plus d'un
mois
on a eu une bonne chute de neige au mois
de novembre 60 cm sur la station qui a
bien pu être préservée dans la mesure où
il a fait très froid depuis un mois où
on a eu du temps très ensoleillé mais
très sec et les canons à neige ont
beaucoup fonctionné puisque après à peu
près un million de mètres cube de neige
ont été créés au cours de ce dernier
mois sur les 3 vallées mais les stations
les plus modestes ne peuvent souvent pas
s'équiper d'un tel matériel leur
rentabilité et donc leur survie est
alors directement liée aux chutes de
neige
l'idée de certains exploitants de mettre
en place un système de mutuelle contre
ce manque de flocons les stations
cotisent et en fin de saison
les sites en difficulté peuvent alors
bénéficier d'une aide financière tout le
monde y trouve son compte
les petites stations garde la tête hors
de l'eau quant aux plus grandes
elle assurera rapide la clientèle des
grandes stations d'une manière générale
et passées par dm stations de basse
altitude où elle a appris le ce qui donc
pourrait dire que les petits stations
sont un vivier pour les grands des
stations d'où l'intérêt d'aider les
petits station et cette assurance dont
la mise en place n'entraînera pas de
hausse du prix du forfait couvrira
également d'autres imprévus comme par
exemple l'isolément d'une station par
une avalanche
un cadeau de noël avant l'heure pour un
chauffeur routier surendetté le fils qui
vient de lui annulé sa dette
écoutez bien le montant il s'agissait de
trois millions deux cent mille francs un
heureux dénouement pour une histoire
franchement kafkaïenne récit florence
griffon 13 ans qu'il en rêvait pascal
simonet va enfin pouvoir vivre
normalement fonder une famille ce
routier se l'interdisent et de peur de
transmettre ses dettes aux siens
aujourd'hui le cauchemar est terminé
il ose à peine y croire j'ai trop galéré
être jeune et robert hue pourra jamais
se refermer il faut que je fonctionne
celle du essayer d'oublier puis referme
un vieux 1987
nicolas simonnet père que deux gendarmes
ce camion est mal assuré son patron
dépôt de bilan
le routier se trouve seul à assumer les
frais de l'accident ces meubles sont
saisis sa maison hypothéquée
il est en effet pour cette génération
jusqu'à ce matin parce que je suis la
lettre ce qui même qui m'a quitté le mal
est si fort que je ne remets pas j'en
reviens toujours je vais je pense j'en
reviens pas en temps nicolas simonnet a
remboursé 122 mille francs au fisc
autant dire que ce cadeau de noël
gardera un goût amer pour certains c'est
un travail pour d'autres c'est un
fantasme d'enfants se glisser dans les
habits du père noël mettre une fausse
barbe et faire rêver
les petits eh bien nous avons essayé
quand je dis nous c'est sébastien legay
reportage avec mathieu dreujou sur une
place parisienne dans la peau du père
noël
il est sorti pour vérifier les commandes
et faire un dernier repérage à cette
occasion le visiteur du nord a accepté
d'être équipé d'une caméra invisible
attention vous voilà dans la peau du
père noël vous allez voir ce qu'ils
voient les enfants dites moi qu'est ce
que vous avez dit non tu veux toi tu
veux quoi tu m'a commandé un château
fort
mais pourquoi avoir choisi d'ouvrir
que tu pouvais pas nui tout ça le père
noël il faut avouer qu'il est
impressionnant certains enfants ont beau
mesurer l'importance de la rencontre
ils ne sont pas fichus de desserrer les
deux jours tu me reconnais je suis qui
je me reconnais
est ce que tu es sage il
d'autres sont plus spontanés bavard et
toi merci
et certains ne font pas mystère de leurs
doutes et comment tu sais ça un dernier
tour de piste un dernier tour de chauffe
il est temps de remonter vers le ciel en
attendant de vous livrer bientôt le père
noël vous saluent bien
voilà bah on va l'embaucher pour la
soirée du comité d'entreprise sébastien
leguay pour les enfants et les parents
spectacle de noël par excellence du
cirque avec ce spectacle intitulé
variété à la cité de la musique à paris
cirque moderne poétique basée sur des
jeux de lumière née du mariage entre le
cirque plume et la musique contemporaine
du compositeur maurice yoka gueule
michel mompontet patrice brugère un
corps au milieu des notes
où les notes comme un décor
inattendu et face au chef tous les soirs
toujours l'inattendu il y à la musique
le mari chuck hagel et puis des corps
qui vole qui rebondissent comme mû par
la musique mais cela s'appelle donc
variété de mauricio qu'agen mais c'est
un spectacle où on ne voit jamais tout à
fait ce à quoi on s'attend
j'ai l'impression que les images où le
spectacle même la relation est tirée
directement de la musique un peu comme
si on est allé à la pêche on a mis des
filets on a tiré tout était dedans et
les filets sont plaints de vision tout
en suspension nouvelle virtuosité exiger
cette fois chez les musiciens
c'est très compliqué et en même temps
c'est très rigolo
au départ bernard nous a demandé si
c'était possible et on est allé tout le
temps dans le possible et si possible au
delà
au delà comme dirait l'autre il y à une
lumière et un certain sens du spectacle
visuel
brillant
ça dure une heure case ça ne ressemble à
rien de connu comme de la musique en 3d
un petit théâtre instrumental ball
rappel des principaux résultats de la
10e 18e journée de division 1 hier soir
défaite de lyon à sedan besoin victoire
2000 match nul d'auxerre
ici les buts de lyon lens a maintenant
cinq points d'avancé sur lyon auxerre et
lille
et puis le tirage au sort des 16e de
finale de la coupe de france quatre
chocs entre équipes de première division
bastia sochaux lens marseille monaco
montpellier rennes lorient
le petit poucet de la coupe issy les
moulineaux recevra amiens club de
deuxième division et finaliste
malheureux l'an passé et puis l'image de
ski avec la victoire du suédois nibe air
dans le 1er des deux slaloms géants de
kranjska gora en slovénie déception donc
pour le français frédéric covili
victorieux deux fois cette saison il a
terminé que 9e il pourra prendre sa
revanche demain
plein de cette édition tout de suite
donc question ouverte olivier mazerolle
et alain duhamel reçoivent le ministre
de l'économie et des finances laurent
fabius l'info sur france 2 20h55 envoyé
spécial guilaine chenu et françoise joly
avec le meilleur des reportages de
l'année les meilleurs une heure du matin
le journal de la nuit jean claude renaud
on se quitte avec un nouveau livre
d'enfant ce soir le clown jaune très
bonnes fêtes de noël